in the previous two videos on cyber
security architecture fundamentals we
discussed principles that you should
follow essential security principles
in the next video we discussed the CIA
Triad where you could basically use this
as a checklist to know that you've done
a cyber security architecture correctly
in this video we're going to focus on
the cyber security architect in
particular their role the mindset that
they have to adopt in developing a
secure solution the tools that they use
tools of the trade and the domains that
they have to operate in all right we're
going to start off with the role in the
mindset where this all begins is with
stakeholders
these are the people that have a vested
interest in getting this solution right
so we're going to take a look at two
examples here of an architect who is
working on a building and an I.T
architect who's working on building an
I.T system in both cases we're going to
start with stakeholders and we're going
to take their inputs into the architect
the architect is going to wonder okay
we're building a building but what kind
of building is this going to be is it
going to be a business is it going to be
a home well in this case we're told it's
going to be a home it's going to be a
multi-family dwelling so it's a
townhouse maybe for instance so we have
an idea already what it's going to be
what sort of size we want what kind of
price range we want it to be in those
are the things the stakeholders are
giving the architect the architect is
going to take that and develop a
blueprint that blueprint then becomes
the plan that the contractors come along
and Implement so we've got contractors
who are plumbers and Carpenter tours and
things of that sort they're going to be
the ones that do the actual
implementation if the architect shows up
on the job site with a hammer in hand
you might be in trouble because that's
not their area of expertise you want
these people that are experts in doing
and these guys who are experts in
planning and coming up with the big
Ideas so that's a little bit of analogy
now an architect might say this is what
I generally want this thing to look like
but we need to take into account some
other things after I've kind of come up
with the basic sketch of what this is I
need to think about Safety and Security
as well with this building so for
instance I want locks on the doors of
course I don't want just anybody to be
able to to walk in I might put security
cameras uh in each of the the units at
least on the outside maybe on the inside
so that again I have an ability to
monitor maybe even alarm systems I might
be concerned about fire in one of the
units so I put a smoke detector on the
ceiling in each one of these so that we
can detect that and then if I actually
do have a fire well I'd like to have
something that we call a firewall that
slows the spread of fire from one unit
to the next doesn't prevent it
completely but at least it keeps it from
spreading really really fast so these
are kind of mitigations things that we
add on to the architecture to make it
more safe to make it more secure and the
architect dreams those up and the
contractors Implement and put those
things together now let's take a look at
an I.T example of the same sort of thing
here once again
we're going to start with stakeholders
and they're going to work with the
architect the architect instead of
coming up with a blueprint is going to
come up with an analogy to that which is
going to be some type of reference
architecture or some type of
architecture overview diagram or
diagrams that show the interrelations of
the high level components of the system
that then is going to get translated
into an actual it architecture so here
we've got in particular a user who is
going to use a workstation maybe a
mobile device or a desktop device
they're going to come across a network
to hit a web server that's going to hit
an app server which is going to hit a
database and we're going to get their
data this is a very simple type of
architecture
now the the architect is then going to
ask the engineers the architect has been
doing their work basically from a
whiteboard think of it this way
Architects whiteboard Engineers keyboard
This is where they're going to be doing
their work as they start implementing
this system
this architect now also has to consider
what might be some failure cases this is
the difference between a sort of normal
I.T architect and a cyber security
architect the normal architect thinks
about how a system will work
the cyber security architect thinks
about how it will fail now the cyber
security architect has to First
understand how the system is going to
work or they don't know how it might
fail so they have to have that level of
understanding then they have to add on
to it what are the possible things that
could go wrong so let's ask what could
go wrong with this user well it could be
someone stole their password their
credentials so it's not this user
anymore so what do I need well I'm going
to put in multi-factor authentication a
mitigation a way to check and compensate
for that particular risk
what if we've got on this workstation a
virus or if it's a mobile device maybe
it's been jailbroken well if it's mobile
device I'll add mobile device management
software detect check for that if it's
another type of device endpoint
detection and response capabilities or
antivirus capabilities to check there
and we continue across this in the case
of the network well just like over here
on this building we added firewalls in
order to keep the spread of a fire from
one unit from immediately spreading to
another and providing a level of
protective isolation that's what we do
with network firewalls that's where we
got that term so I'm going to add
Network firewalls here to slow the
spread of contagion or attack across
this infrastructure and then ultimately
over here I'm going to encrypt the data
that's in the database and I'm going to
ask this it engineer whoever it is and
by the way we'll have different
Engineers that are specialized in each
of these air areas so I might have a
database administrator that does the
database encryption a network
administrator that implements the
firewalls someone else who does the
desktop someone else who does the
identity and access management
capabilities so all of these Engineers
are analogous to the different
contractors and the architect in both of
these cases is coming up with the big
picture the big plans so again think if
you're thinking of a cyber security
architect think whiteboard rather than
keyboard and also think how will the
system fail and what do I need to do to
prevent that
okay now we've covered the role and
mindset of the cyber security architect
now let's talk about
the tools of the trade well it turns out
that in the it architect World there are
certain common diagrams that Architects
use there's a business context diagram a
system context diagram and an
architecture overview diagram are just
three examples that I think are
particularly important so for instance
we'll talk with a business context
diagram here we're trying to show
relationships among the different
entities in the system so an example
here we've got a builder we've got a
marketing team we've got Tradesmen who
are going to build the building and then
a buyer and so we're showing the inner
relationships amongst those various
entities it's a very high level line of
business sort of view
in the next one the system context
diagram we're going to take that and
decompose it further into what it would
look like in a system now this is just
one aspect this doesn't show all of them
by any means but here we have a project
management system there's a finance
system that's trying to oversee and make
sure we can afford to build this thing
the way we need to and on budget
blueprints that we're going to call in
and do the building with a permitting
system that we need to go off and get
those and then a graphical user
interface that interfaces to all of it
that's just a very simple example of of
how the it system that supports this
business model might look then we can
move further down into an architecture
overview diagram in this case now we've
got a project database a scheduler that
is getting status and reports that it's
generating and then alerts whenever
we're over budget or behind schedule or
things like that so you notice with each
one of these it's a further level of
detail a further decomposition Mission
and as I said this is sort of the lingua
Franca the common language of the
architect any I.T architect should be
able to take these kinds of things and
understand what they need to do now a
cyber security architect will look at
this and need to understand how the
system works as I said before they also
need to Envision how the system might
fail so in doing that I'm going to take
this architecture that my it my normal
it architect came up with and I'm going
to try to put the security into this now
that's the typical practice and and the
way we do it remember in the first video
I talked about security principles five
that you should always do and one you
should never do
and in the second video I talked about
the CIA Triad confidentiality integrity
and availability that's a checklist so
we're going to use those things and in
this video I'm going to add another tool
to your toolbox and that's Frameworks in
particular a framework like this one
that comes from the National Institute
of Standards in the U.S it's known as
the cyber security framework and what it
does is it spells out think of a an
architect will need to follow certain
building codes if they're in coming up
with a building if you're an I.T
architect we don't exactly have building
codes that spell it out to that level of
detail but this is an analogy to that so
we're going to specify in the identify
stage these are the things that you need
to do to identify users and data and
things of that sort we're going to spell
out how we're going to protect those
things once we've identified them what
levels of encryption and access control
and things like that that we need how
we're going to detect when we have
problems that we will spell that out
it's this is all listed as a very nice
comprehensive checklist for you to look
at and consider if you've covered all
the bases in the nist cyber security
framework how are we going to respond
once we've detected a problem and then
how do we recover once we realize that
we have now got to get the system all
back and going again so think about this
as a cyber security architect I'm going
to apply these principles the CIA Triad
and some of these Frameworks onto this
now that's the typical practice what
often happens is I get called in at this
phase when the architecture is already
done and they say Jeff make it secure
well we can do it that's the typical
practice but it's not the best practice
it's not the best practice because the
same way you wouldn't like to have the
building architect say we've got the
building built now come in in and make
it earthquake proof it's a little hard
to do now it would have been a whole lot
better if instead of at the
implementation or architecture phase you
had engaged me up here this is the best
practice this is when we ideally want to
be bringing in the security architect
and involve them at literally every step
along the Project Life Cycle so I'm
going to do risk analysis and I'm going
to see what are the risks in each one of
these areas and apply some of these
principles and Frameworks I'm going to
develop a security policy I'm going to
develop then an architecture that goes
along with the overall it architecture
the normal mode architecture so that
security is not just a bolt-on it's
something that was baked in to begin
with and then we add in the
implementation we're looking
architecturally at these security
principles and these Frameworks and
applying them throughout the process
this is how the architect applies their
mindset applies their role and uses the
tools of the trade
okay now we've covered the cyber
security architect's role and their
mindset also the tools of the trade now
we're going to talk a little bit about
the domains that they operate in these
are the cyber security domains that are
the focus of the cyber security
architect so for instance they're going
to take a look at a user who is coming
into a system off of some endpoint
device traversing a network hitting an
application
which pulls data from a database now we
each one of these are domains in cyber
security identity and access management
is where we're looking at the user we're
looking at making sure they're who they
claim to be that they have the right
access rights and things of that sort
that's a whole domain endpoint security
making sure their device is secure and
can be trusted the network itself being
secure the applications can't be broken
into and the data is protected we'll
talk about each one of those domains and
then add two more on top of that because
in fact what we need to be able to do is
take security Telemetry and information
from all of these parts of the working
system the functional system and feed
those into a monitoring system a
security information and event
management capability that monitors all
of this and lets us know if there's an
intrusion or if there's some reason that
we need to go do an investigation and
then ultimately a response if I find a
problem I need to be able to orchestrate
my response to that problem so that we
get it resolved as quickly as possible
these are the seven domains that we're
going to be covering in the rest of the
series
thanks for watching before you leave
don't forget to hit subscribe that way
you won't miss the next installment of
the cyber security architecture series